this year Rainbow six siege in
battlefield hardline are both tackling
hostage rescue modes one with a fast
eSports focus and the other as a
tactical shooter with destructible
buildings not the battlefield one I set
out to research what makes a good
hostage rescue game only to find out
there aren't really a lot of them out
there it's a tough thing to pull off in
PvP because usually one side has an
unfair advantage breathing worse nobody
cares about the hostages and matches
devolve in the team deathmatch here's
some lessons learned from past hostage
games first let's go back to the idea of
hostages as a game mechanic why even
have them traditionally the idea of a
hostage is to slow down a response or as
a bargaining chip in game terms this
hopefully translates into a sense of
tension attackers should be scared and
cautious and turn into defender
territory if nobody cares about the
hostage then you don't really have a
hostage mode you just have a building
entry game so number one both teams have
to have an invested interest in the
hostages safety a good example of this
is in the co-op title payday 2 where
players taking and keeping hostages safe
vastly reduces the difficulty and police
response amateur burglars would blast
their way through levels and then
struggle to survive as increasingly
dangerous police waves showed up to take
them down
but veteran payday 2 players through
unlocked tactics and the keeping help of
zip ties might never have to fire a shot
payday 2 did a great job of tying
hostage treatment to ease or difficulty
of a win early builds of counter-strike
also had issues with hostage value where
terrorists simply found it easier to
manage with fewer and would execute half
for more at the outside of rounds both
of these titles have led me to believe
hostage rescue modes need an instant
fail scenario or heavy penalties for
either side if the hostage is killed it
makes sense conceptually the entire
point of the attackers is to rescue the
entire point of the defenders should be
to escape I'd like to go further and see
the extractions on either side lead to a
win not just the police having to
extract which doesn't give the defenders
any incentive to evade number two tools
for Team tactics are gonna be critical
sure Ghost Recon Future Soldier had some
great sync shotting in single-player but
how do you pull that off with real
players SWAT 4 had some good ideas in
its single-player campaign
the commander led two squads on each
assault and not only gave orders but
look through the helmet cams of his or
her subordinates the commander called
out what kind of preaching and clearing
to do and ultimately led to a unified
tactical response on the flipside for
the defenders that would make the
commander a very juicy high-value target
Ghost Recon phantoms also has a good
solution for team unity with players
being aware of other friendly players
through a friend tracking system that
shows up in the form of lines between a
player and their teammates another way
to encourage team cohesion is gear
splitting if only one guy has the
breaching charges and one guy has the
grappling hook
everyone needs a rally to them to
accomplish tasks I'd love to see a game
where say the bolt cutters were on the
players back and another player would
have to pull it off them to use it so
far we've seen some of these elements in
hardline in siege hardline was spotting
in contextual commands and siege with
gear equipment and voice chat but I am
worried that both of these games hostage
modes will devolve as all players run
off and try to lone-wolf the maps and
that brings us to our last point number
three replayability nothing makes a game
more of playable than a large set of
tools and some randomization payday 2
randomizes doors crates even entire
ships on some levels players are
familiar with the general layout of maps
but they can run into any number of
unexpected barriers SWAT 4 randomize bad
guy placement and bad guys were also
capable of freely moving through levels
once the action started some of this
unpredictability will come naturally
from PvP encounters but environmental
changes would add a lot more content in
terms of gear SWAT 4 had it right
attackers had a wide range of lethal and
non-lethal options grenades and gadgets
there was nothing more entertaining and
also hilarious than running into a room
with a paintball gun full of pepper
spray and shouting get down get down or
you know from doing it boys brutality
ultimately we're gonna see this year
hostage-rescue games and modes are still
appealing I've got great memories from
America's Army - snake plane coop
mission and others in the GameSpot
office recall hunted from team fortress
what would you like to see an either
Rainbow six siege or hardlines rescue
mode leave your thoughts in the comments
below and stay tuned to game spot comm
for continuing coverage of Rainbow six
siege and battlefield hardline